all right welcome welcome what's up hey
what's up what's up you're a Muslim yeah
I'm a Muslim how long you been a Muslim
uh since I was born okay he Bor okay he
born into a Muslim family man I've been
watching you
for I don't know like a good year now a
year okay nice yeah almost a year and
then I'm man I'm like man this guy what
I love about you is that you go Far and
Beyond while I don't like for some
people that talk with you is that they
don't show their face right yeah and
there might be and there might be some
reasons behind that I'm not going to
blame
them but you know first and foremost
thank you for allowing me to talk to you
thanks for coming yeah this is this is
cool for me okay so let's let's have a
conversation I don't think a debate will
get us anywhere because the debate the
principles of the debate is to see who's
house is bigger than the other and
that's not the the point of a of a
conversation in terms of
religion so I agree I will allow you I
will allow you to ask me any question
and then I will ask you any questions
for sure for sure awesome well uh so the
the specific topic I wanted to us to
touch on is this too close I think this
okay the specific topic that I wanted us
to touch on was um how the Quran talks
about the authority of the Bible and how
it specifically points to it being
authoritative over the Quran like if the
Quran lines up with the with the Bible
then um then we know that it's correct
what do you I saw you shaking your head
what you what do you got to say yeah so
obviously before finding you life and
normally I see your lives but I never
find you life and this is a great
opportunity because I see your videos
and then I go to my sources H obviously
the type of Muslim that you talked uh
with I don't know if they're Shia or
Sunni but obviously in the Islamic world
we know that the Sunni is the more I
guess you will call it the Orthodox part
of Islamic part is more traditional yeah
so whenever there is sayings in the the
Quran says that the the Bible the inil
is on power on top of the Quran is not
exactly what it says in the Quran and
the Quran says in
it says that the prophet Muhammad was
sent to confirm that that was written
but in this context of the Quran he's
talking with the Jewish people now most
Christians most Christians are talking
about like oh he's talking about the
Christian people no he's talking to the
Jewish people at the time that came to
find judgment with the prophet now
that's 543 right so so it's not
confirming and saying that inil and Tor
are on top of the Quran because at the
end of the day the whole context of the
Quran is that the Quran is the final
Revelation right that's the context of
Quran again I'm not debating with you to
say that my religion is better no no
this is not the no we're we're we're
here to change exchange ideas and and
talk about our disagreements I think we
could do that here it's all good so if
you if you give me a disagreement
brother trust me you can be as real as
raw as you want to be I love you I love
you so the Quran is in the context of
Quran Quran is the foran is the final
Revelation but it's not saying that the
Torah and the Bible are
confirming like that they are superior
to the Quran most likely in the context
that which most Christians are talking
about is when the Jewish people came for
judgment to the prophet Muhammad and
Prophet Muhammad said well why you find
judgment in me if you have the
books in this ter the and the and theil
is talking about that if they have the
Revelation in which came to Jesus peace
and blessings be upon him and Moses and
David then why are they looking for
judgment with the prophet Muhammad and
that's when the development of the
conversation appears that the prophet
Muhammad says that you change some of
things that appear in your Torah and and
you are changing and developing a
culture based on your liking let me cut
in here yeah let me cut in here so where
where I would disagree is um I would
disagree that they changed their
scriptures um the Quran is very clear
that they distorted they Li they distort
with their tongues they lie on what the
text says right and they try to kind
yeah so what but what I'm talking about
actually is I'm talking about where
Allah in the Quran tells Muhammad that
if he's in doubt about what he's
revealed to
Muhammad um he should go ask the people
who've been reading the scripture before
him no you said no it doesn't say that
no that's chapter 10 verse 94 brother no
it's not telling Muhammed if you're
doubting of what is being revealed to
you it's telling so the sahaba so when
they were with Muhammad if they're
doubting of what is being revealed to
them to go and confirm that what was
written which the Quran does if you read
the Quran and the Bible I mean in some
aspects I read the Bible I have the
Bible here it's in Spanish it's talking
to Muhammad it's talking to Muhammad
right but it's telling him that if the
people that are listening to you are
doubting of what is being revealed go no
it's not no brother I don't mean to cut
you off but yeah he's talking Allah's
talking to Muhammad specifically he's
not talking so he says if you talking to
Muhammad if you are in doubt yeah about
what that which we have revealed to you
um then go and ask the people who've
been reading the scripture before he's
not talking about people surrounding him
he's talking directly to
Muhammad yeah but it's talking to him
referring that whatever he's saying if
there is doubt because remember Muhammad
everything he heard he
said everything he heard he said if you
the context the Arabic word you means
that you as a group you Muhammed and the
people that are listening to you are
doubting that that what is being
revealed then go to the people of the
book because the Quran is confirming
okay I I can work with this so it's not
just Muhammad but even those who are
with Muhammad right in the context in
the Arabic context I'm not
saying I'm with you on that that I can
get with that so so for Muhammad and you
know the Believers who's with him who
he's reciting the Quran to if they're in
doubt about the revelation of the Quran
then they should go and check the
previous scriptures right right now
here's my question why how how how would
it help them how what what's the benefit
of Allah sending them to the previous
scriptures if they're doubting the Quran
of course because the Quran says that um
Muslims and Christians at the time of
prophet Muhammad Christians and Jewish
were kind of combined in the same
population so the Jewish the Gentiles
the the Roman Greek Gregorian Roman
Empire they were all together within the
same religion based on Greek culture so
if they were doubting of what Muhammad
was saying right go to an agreement in
what we have in common and therefore
because he sent to see all those other
scriptures is coming to confirm that
that is which in common because there is
no way this guy that is in the middle of
the desert in Mecca right who is Ed he
doesn't know how to read or write he has
come to know all of
disinformation so so how will how will
his doubts be cleared up how will their
doubts be cleared up if they his doubt
well it says it if if you are in doubt
so meaning Muhammad and everyone with
brother brother please please the
context the Arabic context you must you
must understand the context of the
Arabic when when he's
saying is Muhammad and the people that
suround him I know yeah I know I just
said that I just said that so that's my
question
how would it clear up their doubts about
the Quran if they checked the previous
scripture how would there how will their
doubts if they had doubts
how yeah the doubts come whether this
Revelation is true or not because
remember even in
the I'm not asking where do the doubts
come from I'm asking how will they be
cleared up how will they get rid of the
doubts by checking the previous
scriptures how will the previous
scriptures clear up the doubts that they
may have about the
Quran but when you talk about the do in
which reference you mean like Based On
Believing whether you're giving me the
information this information is true or
not or your religion yeah yeah whe
whether the information that he's given
is true or not because it says that so
Allah in the previous in the previous
verses he's giving him information about
previous prophets a couple of stories
and details okay and so um then he then
we come across this verse 1094 where he
says says so if you're in doubt about
that which we have revealed to you then
go and ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you okay so if they're
having doubts about what they're
receiving this Revelation in the Quran
about the previous prophets and stuff
like that these details their stories he
tells them go check the previous
scriptures how will checking the
previous scriptures clear up the doubts
that they may have about the Quran
because he must confirm that that was
written absolutely
so let me ask you this let to put it
simply if if they went and checked the
previous scriptures and they saw that
hey what we're receiving the Quran
actually does line up with what is came
of for they would know that what they're
receiving is true right right so now
that means that the reverse is true if
they were to check the previous
scriptures and they saw that the Quran
was not lining up with what came before
then they would know that the Quran
they're receiving is not true
right in context kind of yes yes so the
so in this context the previous
scriptures the Torah and theel the Bible
is the authority over the Quran it's
what determines if the Quran is true or
not in this
context and that's that's my point okay
yeah but the Quran confirms that what
was written and that's and see now this
is phase two okay because we know
that this is phase two I know you man I
know you
yeah so phase so phase two is whether or
not the
Quran actually does confirm it now we
know it says it does right it says it
all over the place but is that is that
the truth and so it that the TR we see
when we look at certain things like for
example when we look at the previous
scriptures it teaches that the Messiah
is the Son of God it teaches that the
Messiah was crucified but the Quran
obviously disagrees with those things
yeah mostly when you read Daniel and
asaiah yeah it gives a prophecy but also
for example when you go to some
prophecies of Isaiah when he's talking
to the Jewish people about and I've seen
you react to this question so it's
nothing new to you uh but maybe that's
my point of view that might be different
for example when Isaiah is talking to
the Jew Jewish people about there will
be there will be times when it comes
where they will be offer a scroll and
then they will be tell H to read this
and the people that know how to read
they will say I cannot read this because
it's a sealed scroll a seal book and the
person that comes and don't know how to
read they will tell them read this and
he will say I don't know how to read so
this in in context again Isaiah when you
read Isaiah even if you read in the
Greek parameters right the words are
describing a prophecy because all of his
book is mostly a prophecy we believe
that this prophecy over all so many
prophecies is talking about the prophet
Muhammad okay let's let's let's you said
you saw my video on that yeah and you
still believe
that I follow you man so wait so you saw
my response to don't me that this
discussion I hate you I love you no no I
love you too
yeah so what what I'm saying is I'm
asking so you you saw my response to
that that claim isaah because you're
talking about Isaiah 29 Isaiah 29:12 I
watch you I watch H Sam shamon right
shout out to him and and then what I
noticed is that for example H there is a
lot of context in which you guys explain
certain words about the Quran for
example the names of Allah right Alm Alm
right Alm
here hold on brother that's that's a
that's that's a different subject right
right but what I'm saying is that you're
asking me you have seen my video and you
still believe that and yes because some
of the the the the wording some of the
culture behind the explanation of the
word is incorrect well I'm talking about
I'm talking about Isaiah 29 you saw you
saw my answer on Isaiah 29 yeah you
still believe that that's about Muhammad
yes okay so let's walk through it
together yes sir I have my Bible here
let's go okay English I have it in
Spanish good good good good
good all right and the reason I read a
Spanish Bible just out of for
understanding why I have my Bible in
Spanish is because you speak Spanish
don't you I speak seven languages okay
but Spanish Spanish Spanish is a
language that come close enough to the
meaning of a word in a semantic language
I don't know if you that's perfectly
fine brother it's perfectly fine it's
actually beautiful all right we're gonna
start we're going to start at verse 9
Isaiah
29 we're gonna read from we're gonna
read from 9 to 13 okay I'm 14 sorry
okay
okay almost Which chapter you
said 29 chapter 29
all
right go boss all right so we're going
to start at verse number nine it says
astonish yourselves and be astonished
blind yourselves and be blind be drunk
but not with wine stagger but not with
strong drink for the Lord has poured out
upon you a spirit of deep sleep and has
closed your eyes the prophets
and covered your heads the seers so just
before we move forward I want to make
sure you understand what's going on so
God is actually sending his punishment
upon this people this is Israel
specifically okay and he's punishing
them by taking away his
Revelation so he's blinding the eyes of
the prophets closing closing the eyes of
the prophets covering the heads of the
seers so they're not going to be getting
any Revelation anymore right right for
the at least for this time because of
their Rebellion okay so he continues so
and the vision of all this what he just
described him blinding them him covering
the eyes of the prophets no more
Revelation and the vision of all this
has become to you like the words of a
book that is
sealed when men give it to one who can
read saying read this he says I cannot
read for it's sealed right in verse 12
this is where you what you quote it and
when they give the book to one who
cannot read saying read this he says I
cannot read all of this is an
illustration an analogy on what it's
like when God takes his Revelation from
the people that's what it's talking
about here right okay so he then said
said and the Lord said because this
people draw near with their mouth and
honor me with their lips while their
hearts are far from me and the fear of
of me is a commandment taught by men
therefore behold I will again do
wonderful things with this people with
Wonder upon wonder and the wisdom of
their wise men Shall Perish and the
discernment of their Discerning men
shall be
hidden so you see how God says that
these people are hypocrites they honor
him with their with their lips but their
hearts are far from him these are false
prophets rebellious people who he blinds
and is punishing yeah I understand that
but remember now uh as a in in the
Islamic belief right the Islam makes a
claim I'm not saying that all Muslims we
do it the Islam the Quran makes a claim
that the Jewish people and the Christian
people took some verses out of the
original Revelation and then mix it with
ideology that they thought it was
beneficial for
them right so we don't we don't believe
as Muslims we don't believe that the and
the inil that were revealed to the
prophet were actually the word of God
that that's fine that that's fine even
though that goes against what the Quran
says but let me go with you okay let's
say the Jews edit it edit this up why
would they edit a verse that says that
God is going to punish them and calls
them Hypocrites and says that God's
taken his Revelation from them why would
they edit that to to to condemn them M
themselves God
knows but but that doesn't make sense
right what if they were to edit the
scripture wouldn't they edit the
scripture in their favor in whose favor
in the Jews because it's about the Jews
so wouldn't they wouldn't they edit this
here context in this context God is
talking about those who H love him with
their mouth and their lips but their
heart are far away from him yeah the
Hypocrites right so why why would why
would Israel why would the Jews if
they're editing this
why would they point to themselves as
being Hypocrites and rebelling against
God God knows so this what I'm saying is
let's just use our logic it would make
more sense if they're editing scripture
it would make more sense for them to
edit it in their favor right for them to
talk well about themselves for God to
speak well of them rather than Point
them in a give them an image of being
Hypocrites and rebellious people who God
is going to punish and blind doesn't
that make
sense it does make sense but in the in
the history culturalist history we
believe that what Muhammad said or or
his companions according to Hadith that
the Jewish and the Gentiles at that time
they manipulated the context to their
favor all right but so let let's but
okay to their favor I I'll put the verse
up again I want you to think with me
yeah in what way is God putting a deep
sleep over them closing their eyes of
their prophets calling them Hypocrites
who only honor God with their lips but
their hearts are far from them yeah they
going astray from the law okay so how is
that in how is that talking about
themselves in their
favor so no no no no no so they're going
away from their law God has put them in
a deep sleep in which it has blinded
them from the truth I I we know that my
question is how does that put how is
that talking about them in their favor
when you're talking about when when
we're talking about speaking in the
favor of someone you're speaking good
about that person you're speaking you
know value of this person this is bad
why would they be talking bad about
themselves to edit it that way yeah but
this is not only talking about them but
this is Isaiah saying that the Lord said
about certain people this this is the
Israelites brother you understand that
right okay it's talking about the
Israelites specifically why
would can we agree if we're just being
honest with each other in the text can
we agree that this is not talking well
this is not talking it's not talking
well yeah okay so it wouldn't make sense
for the Israelites to write about
themselves in a nonfavorable
bad light right it doesn't make sense
for them to do that correct so that's
why I'm saying it it would not make
sense for you to say that this was that
they corrupt their text to talk bad
about themselves it doesn't make sense
so for example the question I have for
you now to continue the conversation is
if if the tradition of the Old Testament
is to believe that God is one right so
in the calling of the Israelites we say
Elohim right so God is one so
why why the Bel of the Trinity so why
does this belief we I I I'll be glad to
show you some of this in in a minute but
first I want to solidify the the
confirmation part okay about the Quran
confirming this right because we already
we we established according to 1094 in
that context the previous scriptures is
the authority right and the Quran says
that it confirms the previous Scriptures
it has to it has to line up with them
right so that we know that the Quran is
true if it doesn't we know it's false my
point here is that look just sticking
with the old if we if we stick with the
old t with the Torah alone we see that
the Quran actually goes against the
Scripture it goes against what came
forward of the Torah in which way so
like so for example um the Quran says
that Allah is not a father to anyone
right that he has no children and
anything like unique absolutely yeah
right well in the Torah this is what we
this is what we see in the Torah what
Moses writes okay we go to Deuteronomy
32 all right and we'll go to to verse
6 right here it says let me just
highlight
it so it says do you thus repay the Lord
you foolish and senseless people is he
not your father who created you right
who made you and established you right
so even in the Torah it's it's
recognized that God is our heavenly
father who created us right but what is
the context of being a father well
here's the point according to the Quran
there is no context in which Allah is a
father at all yeah yeah yeah but no no
no but the Quran is in Arabic I know the
word would be AB right AB right but the
father in the context of the Torah you
can ask even a Jewish person you can ask
a Jewish person right now is is God your
father they will say no no no no this is
no they will say yes they will say no
but the Father the context of a Jewish
person saying the father father is being
like the Supreme he is our Lord we are
his son based on kind of like following
the teachings following brother brother
brother you're missing it again so it
doesn't matter what sense you say that
God in the in the Bible is the father
because according to the
Quran there is no sense no way no how
that Allah is a father in any way shape
or form right right the reason be for
that the reason for that brother it's if
the reason doesn't matter right the the
fact that look this is the truth Allah
is not a father in any way shape or form
no way shape or form okay according to
the Torah God is the father in some
sense in the sense that he's the Creator
who who uh who birthed them or whatever
right who started them as a nation
that's according to the tah right thean
then in that context that you're saying
that means that Adam is the Son of God
that means that all the prophets are the
Son of God absolutely yes but Son of God
in which term it doesn't matter because
Allah doesn't have son at all that he's
my daddy right like no but Armando again
pay attention right it doesn't matter in
what sense a prophet or the Israelites
or anybody is a Son of God in the Bible
because it's in no sense that Allah is a
father at all to anyone in any way right
right right so it what whatever sense
the prophets are sons of God or Israel
is the Son of God the Quran disagrees
with it it contradicts it how is it
contradicting it because it says that
Allah is not a father at all correct the
context of this is that because the
Revelation came so what came before
right the Torah right and then the to
David and then Jesus received the inil
and then Muhammad the Quran right so the
Quran is very is is completing that that
was revealed and he's saying he saying
Allah is unique right so in it says say
Allah is
one right there's nothing above it Allah
so it's reason that he's saying this and
he not saying yes God Allah is the
father of this because to the previous
generation in which a revelation was in
Jil the the people of that time took it
the wrong
way they start taking it that yes God
has Sons God can be get and and we don't
see it that way Aran I feel like um like
I i' I've stressed the point and youve
agreed with the point that I stressed
but it's like I don't know if you're not
getting
it I know I know the Torah in theil says
that yeah God is a father in a sense is
Allah a father in any sense not in the
Quran so then why are you like giving an
excuse to say oh well there's a they
used it wrong is there is there any
correct way any correct sense that Allah
is a father no no no not a father at all
good so you see how it do you see how it
doesn't that go that could go in a
difference in terms of the Torah and
inil against the Quran okay yeah but we
see it in a way that H this we don't say
that he's a father in a way because this
could be misunderstand
no worries look look no matter how you I
I understand your view as a Muslim the
point is is that your view as a Muslim
because it comes from the Quran
contradicts the previous scriptures
that's the point so the pre the Quran
even though it says it confirms the
previous Scriptures it doesn't which
means that the Quran is false so other
than this this topic of of father and
and not Father which which is very
polemical because you can put that to
debate now which other you mean put it
to debate what do you mean by that so
because the context the context has to
be clarified right do mean for example
have you been to the Middle
East I haven't yet but what my mom I'm
from Venezuela but my mom and my dad
they're from Lebanon so as a Venezuelan
when I go to Lebanon for the first time
I see a lot of people calling each
other's name which is not meant for
example I see a lot of people calling me
that someone is my uncle someone is my
aunt but in reality there have no
relation towards me so you can see but
again again it seems like you're saying
that you have to
see what what it what they mean by
father it sounds like you're saying that
again right why are you doing that again
when you just acknowledged acknowledged
that it doesn't matter what they mean
cuz Allah's not a
father right in a Bible Allah is a
father in a sense the word father is
mentioned and is in a sense whichever
the
sense and it doesn't appear in the Quran
yeah so in the Quran I'll ask it again
can you said like I don't know why we
got to keep doing this do it again in
the Quran in Islam is Allah a father in
any any way no no so then the Quran
conflicts with the Torah right right in
that sense yeah so which means that it
doesn't confirm the Torah it contradicts
it okay which means that the Quran is
false because here here these are the
steps that we went through we found we
we saw that it's the previous scriptures
that are the
authority we also see that the Quran
claims to be in line with the previous
scriptures if it's in line with them we
know it's true true if it's not in line
with them we know it's false the qu but
you cannot take one word and put it as
it's not in line with none of the text
at all it doesn't wait no it's it
doesn't it doesn't matter if if there's
let's say the
Quran agrees with with the Torah and and
the and the gospel uh you know 10 10
times it agrees with 10 things it says
but disagrees with it let's say even say
five let's say there's five only five
things that disagre right out of a 100
words one is not correct yeah yeah
that's still not a
confirmation really where it says that
well well because look the Torah is the
is the word of Allah according in is the
word of Allah
so yeah so there's no point where the
word of God will contradict the word of
God would you agree correct so if we
believe we believe in the in the
Revelation given to Jesus I know right
so that means that since all of these
Revelations are the word of
God there can't be any contradiction
between them they can't right or else
one is not the word of God doesn't
contradict himself doesn't contradict
himself that's correct so if the Quran
is saying that it is in line with the
previous scriptures yet contradicts them
in any way then it's not the word of
God
correct so if there so if this this one
all I need to show you is one the Quran
contradicts the previous scriptures in
the identity of God that God is not the
father that's huge and so this is a
contradiction which shows that the Quran
is not true it's not the word of God man
it contradicts the word of God that came
before this is how you know yeah but you
no no no no no no but because you gotta
see the context of
it so 600 years apart from culture will
change totally the context of a word
it's kind of for example Islam if you
come to traduce Islam Islam you cannot
traduce it in one word in English or
Spanish it takes five words to take one
word so in into the context we cannot
say 600 years before Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him one word is gonna
be the
same so you in the cont of those people
I believe I believe they call God the
father and God a father in in respect do
you want to see another place where it
doesn't matter you're rep it doesn't
matter bro do you want to see another
place where uh the Quran contradicts the
previous scripture okay okay so the
Quran says that Jesus was not crucified
right correct all right I'mma show you
not just from the inil I'm G show you
from no the Quran says that Jesus at the
crucifixion he was risen to God and he
didn't die someone in place yeah exactly
so I'm G show you where how the Quran
contradicts the previous scripture on
that right let
me it contradicts the inil and it
contradicts the the
Tanakh give me one second I gotta fix
this my phone died and don't mean this
conversation means that I have any hate
against you no brother I don't sense any
Hate in Your Heart All I sense is love
man there you go
like you seem like a cool dude
man all right hold on let me uh just get
get Tik Tok back on there hey guys make
sure you guys are all hitting the like
button especially you guys are enjoying
this conversation um I got to just get
this live set back up on Tik
Tock come on all right there we
go okay sorry about that guys phone died
okay okay so let's see where let's see
how uh I like the commentary is
funny yeah the comments or something
else
yeah this one right here a few things
number one God bless you sir number two
the math ain't mathing and
three beard is healthy thank you man I
work harder man I work hard
okay okay so you believe in the zabor
right the Psalms of David right what was
revealed to him yeah right okay so this
is what David says in the psalm
okay my God my God why have you forsaken
me why are you so far from saving me
from the words of my groaning have you
does it sound familiar to you and that's
what Jesus Christ according to the Bible
said when he was crucified that's what
Jesus said when he was crucified now I
told you man I know you you know this
stuff I love you that's good yeah all
right so let's skip on down it says here
verse 16 for dogs Encompass me a company
of evildoers encircles me they have
pierced my hands and my feet it says I
count on my bones they stare and gloat
over me they divide my garments among
them and for my clothing they cast lots
so they gamble over his clothes which is
what they did at the crucifixion says
they pierced my hands and my
feet what does it sound like to you my
brother Jesus okay so in the Psalms it's
clearly talking about the crucifixion of
the Messiah
right all right and then we have
obviously you already know the the
gospel you know the gospel says that he
was crucified Jesus was on the cross so
you already know that so I don't need to
go anywhere else so you see how the
Psalms and you have the gospel that talk
about the crucifixion of Jesus yeah but
but the Quran says no he wasn't CR
crucified it was only made to appear so
he wasn't crucified in a way that he
died like he
died wait so was he crucified at all
like he was on the
cross I mean yeah they wanted to kill
him and so he was actually put on the
cross you
believe I mean according to what I know
yeah he didn't die there it says they
didn't kill him nor did they crucify him
nor crucify in a context of they didn't
kill him in the cross they didn't
crucify him that they led him there to
die you know so he was put on the cross
but he didn't die on the cross right so
God according to Quran God raised him to
the heavens and put someone that was
enjoying from the public that was
witnessing that put him in his place now
some people this is not in Quran some
people in the Islamic community says
that God put Judas into his place now
this is not Islamic belief this
is histories right mhm right but we it's
not history the heavens you saying this
is what Islam this is what Islamic
scholars say they say some say Judas and
right some stor said that and you know
yeah but that's that's that's completely
that's that's Islam yeah that's that you
can leave aside yeah well that's
important because they're coming up with
conjecture they're making up stuff yeah
but some had some you gotta see it in a
way that you know you we for example
Sunni Muslims we go by solemnly what is
in the Quran and the that is being
verified gotcha so you believe that he
was crucified but not he didn't die on
the cross he was on the cross but just
didn't die he survived corre Allah took
him up before he died yes okay all right
so now let me show you the other one I'm
pretty sure since you said you've been
watching so you know this too okay yeah
let's go so this is Isaiah 53 right it
talks about but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the chastisement
the punishment that brought us peace and
with his wounds we are healed all we
like sheep have gone astray we have
turned everyone to his own way and the
lord has laid on him the iniquity of us
all the sins of us all all right and you
you agree that this is talking about
Jesus the
Messiah I mean yeah according to context
yeah absolutely and it says here and we
keep keep on reading because I want to
show you that he uh that he dies here it
says here in verse uh verse 12 therefore
I will divide him a portion with the
many and he shall divide the spoil with
the strong because he poured out his
soul to death and was numbered with the
transgressors yet he bore the sin of
many and makes intercession for the
transgressors right so in this context
bra Bravo so in this context of Isaiah
right in this context We Believe or the
Islamic World believe right that there's
some pieces that were taken and were
misplaced for but that's the Islamic
belief yeah so armano I I want you to be
uh to be real yeah be sincere here okay
because I know the Muslim claim but do
you see how that claim doesn't work it's
a topout what whatever we disagree with
we're going to say that that's been
changed even though we have no evidence
nothing supporting that claim it's just
a claim because we're Muslim and we know
that if we acknowledge this this goes
against us it'll prove us wrong so let's
just say it's been corruptive that's not
sincere
man well we don't say we don't say that
because it goes against us we we don't
we we believe so to become a Muslim to
be a Muslim is to acknowledge everything
that the prophet Muhammad p is and bl
upon him said so we don't go anything
against what he said so if is revealed
then we believe it so if he said that
the the the Jews at the time of him and
theil was not fully corrupted because we
believe the Bible he never says it was
corrupted at all he says he believed in
it if you want to say that it's
corrupted and you're going against your
Quran again the Quran is not the
authority over the previous scriptures
it's the previous scriptures that's the
authority so where where in the Quran
says that the the we believe in theil
and and the Torah chapter 3:3 it says
that we sent down the Torah and the and
theil as a go as a guidance and light
for mankind for for the people of it
doesn't say for anyone it says for
mankind actually look let me show you it
says mankind U let's go sah 33 and
four let me show you
someone says in the comment but believe
blindly because only Allah knows don't
ask questions and be inconsistent with
your own book look at this look at this
it says it is he who sent down the book
this is chapter 3 verse3 okay it is he
who sent down the book to you with truth
confirming what came before it and he
sent down the Torah and the
inil Before Time as a guidance to
Mankind and he sent down the criter
truly those who believe in the Ayah of
Allah for them there is a um who don't
believe there is a sever toy truly those
who believe yeah okay but he's talking
about the context of that is is talking
to the people of that time but it says
of mankind right right mankind all no it
doesn't say at that time bro mankind is
all time a four time as a guidance to
mankind as he sent down the Criterion of
judgment between it doesn't it doesn't
stop there there so even it doesn't stop
there okay good so even until today it's
it's still a guidance and light so my
point is is that it's it's insincere to
go to when we look at the previous
scripture you see that it clearly
contradicts what you believe and to say
oh well you know I'm I'm a Muslim so
that's just been changed it's been
corrupted that's insane that's like me
going to the Quran and saying oh this
part that I disagree with as a Christ
I'm a Christian I believe Jesus Is God
so the part in the Quran that says that
Jesus is just a messenger oh that's just
been changed that they corrupted that
you see how dishonest that
is so don't do that don't don't don't be
that person no no man I'm just having a
conversation right so for me for me for
me I have to be honest enough to say I
grew up Muslims and I can recite the
Quran right but even me and some people
that I know that are all Elders some
parts of the Quran that don't understand
why because it's a former Arabic and
then you must understand the context for
us for us when we look at information
specifically biblical Torah or or or
Quran we must understand the context of
the word because we might read a word
and it doesn't mean that yeah that's
that's fine and all but this is exactly
what it means this is clear right this
is perfectly clear that the Messiah is
gonna die and take on the sins of the
world that's what this that's what this
whole passage is talking about right
right according to the Torah right so we
have here according to the Torah that
it's not just just that the Messiah gets
crucified and survives no he gets
crucified and he dies and why does he
die for our sins for our
transgressions and the gospel says the
same thing so we have the Torah we got
the zabor we got the gospel all agreeing
that the Messiah dies for the sins of
the world and is crucified for the for
mankind but the Quran contradicts
that so we see here the
Quran it says that it confirms the
previous scriptures but it doesn't it
contradicts them which means the Quran
is false in the context of Quran it it
confirms that what was written in terms
of the conversation of Muhammad with the
people at that
time okay well with that being said um I
I do hope to see you again I do got
other guests to get to right but but I
did have a did you have fun one one
thing I will say is that not every Trad
translation of the Arabic context of the
Greek context means exactly what the
translation is like I said like I said
at the beginning right imagine that
imagine not being able read if I read
the the Spanish Bible right and I read
an English Bible the wording is totally
different it's totally different it's
not totally different it's totally
different for example in John in John
the English Bible says that the word was
with God and the word become flesh yeah
in Spanish it says the verb which aligns
with what the Quran says the verb is the
action so be and it is no it doesn't it
says the word in Spanish no in Spanish
says the ver ver all right well no
worries um I I hope that you you know
just think about what we talked about
today man Ponder on it and uh we'll talk
again someday yeah so we have to make
sure the translation is correct man yeah
or else we can't we can never understand
God's word unfortunately I
mean all right take care
man yeah um you know that's that's
that's tough here you know you can you
can you know bring someone to to to the
to the lake to drink right you could
lead them to the water but you you can't
force them to drink all right so agree
with all the premises but disagree with
the
conclusion uh we got